for the first time we are all seeing the
exact moment that the Cardassians found
out that Tristan Thompson was reportedly
cheating on Khloe Kardashian it's airing
in this weekend's episode of Keeping Up
with the Kardashians here's the preview
that's just been released there was
video Tristan making out with a girl
last night I know Khloe's gonna bad
woman who filmed the clip said I was
there and he was on the table right next
to us with a group of friends everybody
watched them make out
times no one had the courage to tell
Chloe because we knew she was days away
from giving birth we didn't want to
stress her out but we knew that it was
the right thing to do
so I'm moving the toll Chloe I didn't
want to hurt her feelings but I felt
like she should hear from one of us
verses on the Internet
oh my god oh my god I'm gonna cry for
her she's literally gonna go into labor
I'm gonna okay
the thing we hear about these things we
report on them we learn about them and
then I'm keeping up with the kardashians
we see the behind the scenes you saw
Khloe's sisters finding out there that
her boyfriend
Tristan Thompson now the father of her
child had allegedly cheated on her in
that scandal what we do know are ET
reporting on where things stand now with
Chloe and Tristan is the chloe has flown
back to Cleveland recently to be with
Tristan she's supporting him at his
basketball games and that they are
working on things their daughter true is
their number one priority right now
though Chloe is not certain how long she
will stay in Cleveland of course she's
got her mom Chris's birthday coming up
so we'll see what happens but that's the
moments that it all went down
[Music]
[Applause]
you